i can finally say what i want because i
have no script to adhere to welcome to
the how not to summon the demon lord
season one review
if you thought i was gonna do a proper
intro to this then you're [ __ ] crazy
i'm just kidding
you're not crazy like i just got a
little excited because it's my first
review
welcome to the first review look at the
look at the things
i did the things i just want your
approval okay so i've been thinking how
do i want to do review videos
because there's a lot of review videos
out there so it's like what makes mine
special could come up with some generic
writing system
music three why not enough violin and
you guys are like whoa
i don't even think about the lack of a
violin this guy really knows what he's
talking about coaches make jokes all the
time
everybody knows that zoomers have their
tick tocks and [ __ ] nobody has time to
sit down and listen to something so they
have to have jokes and constantly like
[ __ ] dopamine
[ __ ] doping me more dopamine give me
more dopamine
and then if you don't do that they get
bored they're like oh my god
this is so this is so boring what do we
do
everybody has adhd nowadays it's like
[ __ ] just relax
just watch the video so i have to talk
really [ __ ] fast and then i have to
slow down randomly to enunciate
and that way people think like wow this
is really thought provoking
while simultaneously not providing any
useful information in any way at all
i could target shows for incredibly
obvious reasons hey thanks for making
the entire show good
and then just [ __ ] ruining it at the
end i was really hoping
that i could just waste as much time as
physically [ __ ] possible
before you ruined it let's make sure
they're interested peaking wait for it
wait for it ruin the show ruin it go
because now i can build a rapport with
you
and you're like oh my god i think that
too got
was a shitty ending yes it was but don't
think that i'm original for thinking
that
you know why because everybody [ __ ]
thinks that that eddie was garbage so i
thought about it for a long time and i
was like what do i want to do for the
video how do i want to make it and i
just thought yes i'm just gonna do all
that
[ __ ] and then see what happens the great
thing about not having a very successful
channel is that nobody gives a [ __ ] if
you fail
if i just shoot and fail that there's
like three people who are disappointed
who cares
look you guys probably watch more anime
than me and you read more manga than me
so the question becomes why would you
listen to me
i don't [ __ ] know maybe i'll find it
in lightning to your life in some way
maybe i'll get out of depression finally
maybe i'll get a girlfriend want a
girlfriend
i mean if you meet her and then she's
like i watch that guy and then you're
like i watch that guy too
babies all i'm trying to say is that i
don't know what i'm talking about none
of us know what we're talking about all
we do
is form opinions and then we spew those
opinions on everybody else's existence
and then
sometimes it'll stick people watch it
and i might make money
if you are looking to get immersed in a
dense world with
ever-changing plot twists and characters
that are relatable with everything you
could ever imagine great soundtracks
you're in the wrong [ __ ] place but if
you like titty filler content bath
scenes incest rate major orgasms minor
orgasms and
minor orgasms why did he say that twice
you'll [ __ ] find out
how not summoned to demon lord is just
one of those anime where if you try to
pay attention and take it seriously
you're going to lose brain cells but if
you just turn off every nook and cranny
of your brain
then you'll have a good time it helps to
be sexually frustrated too but that's
aside the point
it's not really that far aside the point
it's kind of the main point you would
watch it why do you need to be sexually
frustrated to enjoy the show i'm glad
you asked your child come sit down
let's talk about it it's because it's
just sprinkled with a lovely
pretty tight fan service to distract you
from your problems
and the one-dimensional plot the plot
had potential i guess it revolves around
an op character gets transported to
another world inadvertently gets two
slices because they're stupid as [ __ ] i
don't know it's like you could make it
fun
you could make it fun i guess this guy's
a shut-in from our world so then he gets
her and he's like oh man what a drag two
new slaves let's really work together to
break the enslavement i wouldn't i'd be
like
unlucky come on you're mine now let's go
and of course this branches into a bunch
of different side quest
let's be honest it's not why we watch
this show we all know why
you might say i just want to watch all
the shows i can
i want to study the art of the anime so
i can improve my own work
i seek spiritual enlightenment from the
enemy
but we all know that it's because of the
tits
there are huge tits small tits
cat ear orgasms noob shots
just disappointing enough to not be
classified as hentai speaking of hentai
why not just watch hentai you know
damn well why because people might think
you're weird what happens when your
roommate comes in or your mom or dad or
wherever you are in life
and they see all this lube and tentacles
flying everywhere you can't explain that
[ __ ] but if they come in on this show
then you could just be like no no
you're a misunderstanding the there's
they're enslaved
hello and then they have to go and break
the enslavement
obviously you're probably still naked
and rock hard but at least it sounds
better the thing with the show is that
if you watch it sexually repressed then
you'll be like oh yeah
interrogate that cat girl harder make
her talk but then once you come you'll
be like well this seems invasive
you could just build mutual respect and
trust between one another and get the
information that way also
moral of the story watch the show horny
if you can't do that then just pick a
different asakai like one with a blue
haired mage or something but
don't make any videos on that anime
because counter color corp is [ __ ]
crazy
all of that being said i would give how
not to summon a demon lord an
astonishing forgettable out of ten and i
would tell you why but i don't [ __ ]
remember
[Music]
that's the general overview if you want
to watch it or not so now i'm going to
start going into more detail so
warning spoilers ahead don't want to
spoil the show a dense plot spoiler
number one
rem is 14. huh you break this up at
every video you've done on this show
yeah you want to know why she's [ __ ]
14. how's that not gonna be a massive
point of interest in the video
[ __ ] the plot let's talk about all the
crazy [ __ ] that happens with rem
oh i have a secret diablo's like i'll
get this secret out of her hold my beer
and then he goes in
pins her down and then starts like
[ __ ] caressing her ears she's like
you like that
tell me tell me and she has some sort of
erotic response from it like oh no
my ears being touched i'll tell you
anything it was like what happened
who came up with the ear meta to where
like if you rub an ear
all of a sudden it's orgasmic and then
if you take a normal cat you rub their
ear i'm sure they like it wait
they do like it i have a cat ipad is
here all the time it's a guy
let's just back burner that for now and
we'll just focus on rem's explosive
orgasm at 14 and then the writers are
all sitting around like how else were we
supposed to get her to tell him
and then all the the horny nerds in the
dark like pausing to like finish are
just like
yeah exactly and then all the
well-adjusted nerds who have already
come are just sitting there like
she's 14 though right it says we're here
i mean we might as well go down the path
you know what path i'm talking about the
summoning ritual
let's [ __ ] talk about it let's talk
about let's talk about the summoning
ritual this scene
is where the show peaked and it was so
necessary because it brought
everything together for this storyline
the plot you guys the plot you see the
pattern though they take this messed up
scene and they sprinkle in
just enough plot to be like well it's
justifiable now
how else is he gonna summon the demon
lord all the horny nerds are like yeah
summon that demon lord you know you
gotta summon it right and then all the
well-adjusted nerds are like closing the
browser like what in the [ __ ] and then
they reopen in like private browsers and
stuff look some people really like these
shows and that's okay
i think that it just comes down to a
lack of meaningful content instead of
making some complex story you just have
to be like no he's summoning a demon
lord so that he can feed it at face
value
one dimensional but if you make it so
that he has to finger a girl so that he
can summon it
then it's like original technically but
it's not really original in a meaningful
way it's just like nobody's ever done
that because it's like what the [ __ ]
would do that
this just seems like a common theme
shira wants to avoid an arranged
marriage never heard that before but no
it's different because it's her
incestuous brother that tries to rape
her yeah sure i don't know any shows
based around that nuance but if you take
the core concept
it's still generic it's just an arranged
marriage granted it is really hard to
make an original concept these days
bordering impossible so turning to kinks
and fan service is an easy way out
there's obviously nothing wrong with
that but when it comes to raiding the
plot i'd have to give it a whopping
generic with fetishize who wants to tie
blues heads out of 10.
well let's just look at the characters
diablo is just one of those characters
that does things because the writers
think it's funny
not really because a person in his
situation would ever
actually consider doing these things for
example he was a shut-in during his past
life which is fine but then when he goes
to the new world he can't interact with
anybody in a healthy way so he has to
interact
the way a demon lord would so he gives
off this menacing vibe which just seems
like such a hyperbolized solution to
finding a way to interact with people
but they did it because the writers
thought it would be funny
in my line of work i have talked to a
lot of degenerates and a lot of people
with social anxiety and problems with
interacting with people
and nobody would try this why because it
doesn't [ __ ] make any sense
this makes it really hard to relate to
him and this construct was introduced so
early that it ruined my immersion
instantly as far as the side characters
go sure they have q mannerisms all that
stuff but really
it just feels like they're there to get
groped throughout the entire season
everybody that was incorporated into the
show was either
saved groped or defeated by diablo the
only one to do
anything was [ __ ] burger when he saved
shira everybody else
[ __ ] useless basically just
decorations to harness the male sex
drive to farm views
the only noticeable character
progression is maybe rem deciding to
like get along with krebs gollum but
aside from that what we got shira for
giving her brother that doesn't [ __ ]
matter he died immediately after so it's
like
nobody's progressing anywhere it's
completely possible that my expectations
for anime are just too high these days
there can only be so much character
progression with side characters
in a 12 episode series but maybe if you
took
some of the time that you put into
animating the boob physics or trying to
make these crazy fingering scenes like
legal and justifiable
you just took a little bit of it and put
it into the character and character
progression
then i wouldn't have to give it a who
[ __ ] cares because the rating system
never mattered anyways out of two
point five there's obviously a market
for these kinds of anime so i'm not
gonna say don't watch it
all things considered if you just shut
off your brain it's not that bad it's a
decent filler series between watching
mainstream shows
are the fbi gonna be watching you of
course she's [ __ ] 14
but just you're lonely anyways just
pretend that they're close friends
who really care about your opinions and
thoughts
and actions and your pending threat on
society but aside from that it's not
weird i'm going to be doing the next
season and you can find that in the left
side whenever i'm finished with it or
you can check out all the reviews and
recaps for how not to summon a demon
lord in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros
is outros